president is kicking off his five-day
swing through Asia where he's expected
to meet with other world leaders
including a highly anticipated meeting
with Chinese president Xi Jinping Biden
arrived in cambodia's capital Friday for
the association of Southeast Asian
Nations Summit
CBS news's Elizabeth Palmer reports on
this
good morning
President Biden traveled all all the way
to Cambodia to attend this Summit in
person sends a powerful signal in
thanking the summit's host Cambodian
prime minister Hansen and posing for a
picture with asean leaders he's
telegraphing America's determination to
bolster its alliances in the
indo-pacific to help counter and contain
a rising China asean is the heart of my
administration's in the Pacific strategy
U.S officials are offering support and
investment asean countries in a whole
range of areas from digital connections
to helping to police illegal fishing but
China has been bankrolling huge
infrastructure projects like dams and
highways across this region for years
and this is a race for influence that's
heating up
while asean leaders welcomed the
president and want to engage with
America they can't afford to alienate
China which remains their biggest
trading partner
for the moment anyway America and its
Western allies are mounting a charm
offensive and the asean Nations don't
have to choose signs
Japan and South Korea though not asean
members are major Military Allies of the
United States and this fall they've
joined U.S forces in big joint exercises
on Sunday President Biden will meet here
in Cambodia with both the Japanese and
the South Korean leaders right after
that the president will fly on to
Indonesia for the G20 conference and the
most important meeting of this whole
trip a face-to-face sit down with
President Xi Jinping of China Elaine
Liz thanks